[Music]
yeah welcome to all of you and thank you
for coming to the second lecture of this
fall's lecture series God and computers
minds machines and metaphysics to start
the whole thing we also have a website
several people asked for that I just
wrote down the address so if you want to
check the website if you want to see
future speakers the abstracts and so on
even though I have to warn you the
abstracts usually come only one week
before the actual talk the address is
HTTP www.mit.edu slash events slash god
- and that computer HTML last week I
forgot but this week I definitely want
to at first start this thing by thanking
all the organizations which support the
series which is the MIT Electrical
Engineering and computer science
department the artificial intelligence
lab the Boston Theological Institute the
Sir John Templeton Foundation the center
of the studies of values in public life
of Harvard Divinity School and the face
and science exchange in Boston I thank
all this organization for very generous
help not only financial but also in
terms of organization and stuff and I
also want to mention that the discussion
group we have organized at Harvard which
is run by Professor Harvey Cox and me
actually does not take place next Monday
before God it's Columbus Day so
unfortunately this thing will not happen
so we will meet the first time on the
27th of October outside a brochure so if
you want to have the dates for all three
meetings look in this brochure but the
changes unfortunately I'm sorry to say
that but the meeting is not at 1:00 but
at 12 o'clock in the refectory in the
small dining room at Harvard Divinity
School 45 Francis Avenue you might find
it on any Harvard map I guess and it's
open for the public so anyone can come
and for students it's for non-credit
it's just for the interest of this thing
and now it is my absolute pleasure to
introduce mark Hauser the second speaker
of this series
mark is currently associate professor in
the department's of anthropology
psychology and the program in
neuroscience at the Harvard University
he's also member of two
interdisciplinary faculties the speech
and hearing science program of MGH
Harvard and MIT and the mind branded
behavior program at her 'but he has
worked with several various monkies
group on a variety of different problems
like aging parent offspring and gender
relationships sexual behaviors facial
expressions perception and repeatedly on
language and communication this last
part of Mark's research has led to the
1996 MIT press book the evolution of
communication and while reviewers all
say that this book has a clear potential
to become an absolute classic in the
field I like it because it's absolutely
fun to read and so in that sense I can
highly recommend that book for anyone
who is interested in this sort of thing
my first I first met mark when we were
in our robotics group questioning of
dealing with questions of self-awareness
and we had this big problem to
understand what that is in the same time
I lost the bet and so I was forced to
dye my hair purple and so my boss Rodney
Brooks looked at me and said well you
know what there is this guy at Harvard
who dyes monkeys hair blue and he found
out that they have self-awareness that
way and this is how I met mark
so mark I'm very happy that you are here
to share your ideas on send perceptional
self and mortality
I I suppose the title like the one I
gave I should be a little bit humble so
I'll start out by telling you a story
about my daughter who has always sort of
taught me some interesting things and
when she was about four I walked into
her room and she was sitting on the
floor with a book between her legs and I
noticed the book was upside down I said
to her Alexander you're the books upside
down and she sort of looked at me and
looked at the book and said yeah but the
world is upside down and I thought you
know well I guess it is just a matter of
perspective and what I wanted to do to
you with you today is sort of share a
perspective that I sort of hold dear to
my heart and that's a perspective that
Charles Darwin brought to us I don't
know if we need the lights down a little
bit maybe can you have the lights down
yeah it's by good in one sense the topic
for this series Godin computers I think
Darwin has some interesting things to
say the Darwinian revolution has often
but been put in opposition to religion
but as many of you know Darwin himself
was quite a religious man and of course
what Darwin which try to force us to
sort of take seriously is the idea that
there is continuity between humans and
nonhumans and Darwin easily could be
considered one of the first
psychologists because Darwin took the
idea very seriously that not only do we
share continuity in terms of what we
look like in terms of our morphology but
also in terms of how we felt about the
world and how we thought about the world
now we have this extraordinary
fascination with our uniqueness and in
fact we could almost say it's an
obsession with our uniqueness to the
point where we have movies trying to put
ourselves in opposition to the animals
or having the animals rule us and we
think this is kind of cute but of course
we know it's not possible but this
obsession I think blurs what are really
the important questions about thinking
about our evolution that in one sense
all animals come into the world with
special features things that make them
special and unique
so the claim that we're unique really
just begs the question unique in what
way and what I hope to reveal
to you today is some of the ways in
which we are special but also some of
the ways in which we share common ground
with many other animals now how can we
study the evolution of something so
complicated as our minds the fossil
record of course is in some sense quiet
on this problem because they're not
around and tell their tale but on the
other hand there are some lively things
that are left in the past
that we can use to understand what was
going on artifacts for example are
really traces of a mind from the past
and archaeologists and paleontologists
have done some extraordinary work
working out the details of things like
artifacts when fire came into existence
when artefacts tools art religion began
to come around well I want to sort of
push this further back then those guys
and I want to deal with the creature for
the moment that is very very different
from us and I want to bring up this
creature for a very particular reason
and it's because in the area of
philosophy in a particular philosophy of
mind people such as Thomas Nagel have
thrown out the question what is it like
to be a bat well what is it like to be
any type of creature other than
ourselves and his answer and managers
that many people have given is that
there is no such thing that's like to be
another animal because our sensory world
our perceptual world is so critically
different from that of another animal
surely it's different from a bat who
sees the world so to speak with its ears
they sent out a BIOS on our pulse the
virus on our pulse hits objects in the
world and this gives them a menu of
possible objects that are in their
environment so how could we possibly
understand what their beliefs their
thoughts their emotions are like if
their whole sensory system is so
different well if you don't want to buy
that bats are a good model for our
thinking well then I think the primates
should probably be a little more
digestible to you because they're a
little bit more closely related this is
the comparison group that I want to talk
about today my daughter when I showed
her the slide a smiie why that one was
over there rather than somewhere down
here she's got quite sophisticated with
her phylogenetic thinking and I want to
in fact talk to you today in particular
about three
species the three species I've been
working on for the last 15 years and
their representatives although I need no
means though representatives of their
taxonomic groups and that's the
chimpanzees who are great apes closely
related to the gorillas and orangutans
an oval monkey in particular the rhesus
monkey very close related to species
like baboons and vervet monkeys that you
may be familiar with and a new world
monkey the cotton-top tamarin now unlike
some of the people that you'll be
hearing in this series who work in labs
with robots and so forth I work in a
variety of places and this sort of
informs how I go about thinking about my
work so I want to share a little bit
without you with you right now the
chimpanzees that I study live in a
forest in Uganda it's a tropical
rainforest and the chimpanzees have
become very a [__] waited to the
presence of humans so we can watch a
detail their behavior and I'll be
telling you a little bit about that at
this into the last part of the talk
rhesus monkeys these guys here the ones
I study they're actually from India but
they were imported in 1930s to a small
island off the coast of Puerto Rico
known as Cayo Santiago and for those of
you who think that field research is
tough this is the place that we work on
it's not tough at all in fact the pina
claws are somewhere over here and then
lastly the cotton-top tamarin that we
study at our lab at Harvard University
okay so those are the cast of characters
the outline for my talk today is gonna
be sort of like a version of Sesame
Street but with hopefully a little bit
more content for you and it's been
broken into approximately four parts in
the first part I want to touch upon an
issue which which I mention at the
beginning of today's talk which is the
notion of self and to try to work out
how we could understand whether other
creatures have a kind of itself and if
so whether it's different from ours and
if it's different in what ways might it
be different and if it's the same
wouldn't that be interesting the second
part is to say if they do have some
understanding of self can they apply the
knowledge that they have to make
predictions about the minds of others
can they mind read in the way that all
of you are capable of mind reading every
single day you are constantly making
predictions about other
people without any experience but what
they're doing you see somebody they say
to you I have the following religious
affiliation you say aha I bet you
believe the following ok you merely jump
to that conclusion do animals have such
capacities part three will be to focus
on the notion of death do animals have
any understanding of their mortality and
then lastly taking all three those
issues together I will touch briefly
upon the notion of morality to see
whether or not animals could possibly be
moral creatures in the way that we think
were moral creatures ok so so this is a
Tigger from Winnie the Pooh and Tigger I
won't read through the whole thing but
it surprised to see himself in front of
a mirror because he thought that he was
the only Tigger in the world so the
mirror for Tigger is a reflection of
another he doesn't get what the mirror
should be telling him now is there
anything natural about the situation for
animals in the wild well yes there is
animals often might see themselves in a
mirror reflection and that's water so
there are situations where animals like
these fowl might have the opportunity to
get information about themselves and if
this kind of reflection that might tell
an animal that it is a unique individual
and this might be the beginning stages
of the development or the emergence of a
sense of self but how can we get further
on this problem let me tell you about
what I think of is one of the most
ingenious experiments I think to ever
come out of the field of animal behavior
because it's so very simple it actually
started with Charles Darwin in the
expressions of emotions in man and
animals Charles Darwin thought to
himself I wonder if animals have a sense
of self and he thought let's see let's
put up a mirror in front of an orangutan
which is exactly what he did and what he
found was the orangutans were interested
they went up and looked in the mirror
they often looked behind the mirror and
they displayed at the mirror and Darwin
thought well based on this kind of
aggressive kind of display it seems that
things do not have a sense of self they
think that the mere reflection of
somebody else in the same way that
Tigger did but it's also possible which
Darwin did acknowledge that they were
trying out their displays acting Gresley
see what they look like boy don't I look
good in that mirror
we can't distinguish that so along comes
Gordon Gallup a comparative psychologist
in 1970s who decides that we need to
detest this a little more warmly so he
presented the chimpanzees a mere a full
standing mirror and he what them watch
and he watch what they did and they did
the same thing that the Iranians did
they touched the mirror they inspected
it they looked at themselves and so
forth and after exposure to the mirror
he needs the ties of chimpanzees knocked
them out of the drug and while they were
sleeping he placed a red mark above one
eyebrow and a red mark above the
opposite ear and when they woke up he
put the mirror in front of them and what
he found was the chimpanzees directly
touched those marks on their eyebrow and
the mark on their ear and not the
opposite ones and from this kind of
observation and others such as the
following of chimpanzees now beginning
to use the mirror to find good things
like picking their noses flipping their
lips up and see what they look like all
these body parts they've never seen
before what a revelation right Gordon
Gallup included that not only do
chimpanzees recognize themselves in the
mirror in other words they know that
that's me but they have something much
more profound which is a sense of
self-awareness now maybe in the
questions we can come back to this issue
but it suggests a pretty profound
difference that to recognize one's self
in the mirror seems to me at least quite
a different type of claim than the claim
that they are aware of themselves that
they are aware in some sense of what
they believe and that they know that
those beliefs in some sense are
different from the beliefs of others
well if you work on a species which has
been tested in the same type of design
and fails you feel like you've got a
really dumb species so you worry about
it a lot and the one species that we
work on the terror which I mentioned
before
focus sorry was a species that I've been
test on the Gallup test with these marks
on the eyebrow and they basically fail
and we thought well look why might they
fail this test and if they fail you'll
doesn't really tell us they lack a sense
of self so we worried about this quite a
lot we thought well look why am i tamron
fail well one reason why it's hammer in
my fail is because maybe because they
have a black face the red mark
is it really that distinctive they might
not notice it the other thing is
tamarins like all other monkeys and in
contrast the Apes like chimpanzees find
looking at somebody else to be aversive
staring is not good staring is a threat
and if staring is a threat and your
first implication that you draw from
seeing the mirror is that it's somebody
else then the mirror is aversive so you
might not never pick up the details of
what a mirror gives you which is
something about real-time coordination
between your emotion and something else
so we thought look we've gotta do
something really dramatic that'll make
them pay attention and that's what we
did we dye their hair as Ann told you
and to do this required some very
delicate equipment it required us going
to hubba-hubba which I'm very sorry to
say no longer exist in Central Square to
buy Manic Panic and we dyed our monkeys
with this Manic Panic different colors
you can see here some had green some in
purple some had blue pink and so forth
and we ran exactly galip's tests and to
our great surprise when the tamron saw
themselves to the mirror they also touch
their hair but they did something which
to us was far more interesting and that
sort of shown in one of the few data
slides I'm gonna have in a moment which
is that unlike what they did before
their hair was dyed the chairman's with
their hair dyed now looked at themselves
in the mirror for a very long time so
this is what happened to those animals
before their hair was dyed and this is
what happens to them after their hair
has died they sat in front of the mirror
peacefully without vocalizing without
aggressively displaying just looking in
the mirror some would put their hands in
front of the mirror and watch the
reflection as they moved it round and
round
others would go up in front and check
out their backsides they began to use
the mirror in this subtle kind of way
now it wasn't as dramatic as the
chimpanzees but it suggests a similar
kind of phenomenon that minimally
perhaps the chairman's perceive
themselves in the mirror as themselves
we think however this experiment is
completely silent when it comes to
revealing anything about what they think
about in terms of themselves what they
believe whether they really have
self-awareness now I want to share with
you
a videotape of something that we
recently saw on the island of Cayo
Santiago with the rhesus monkeys this is
a population of about 900 monkeys living
in Island no people live there at all
and to our knowledge they really have
not been exposed to any kind of mirror
well a few weeks ago I sorry a few
months ago when I was down on the island
of Cayo Santiago the film crew was there
from the BBC and they were interested in
what rhesus would do in front of a
mirror sadly enough the mirror broke so
they never got any footage but we were
able to get some because for females
picked up these fragments of mirrors and
carried them around everywhere okay why
aren't we going here
we're having technical difficulties here
hitting all the right buttons but it's
not moving yeah it's on a cuz that light
up the blue screen so it's slope it's
the machine which is not going rather
than the nope yeah that's a good point
thank you talk about human technology
why is it doing I'm not from MIT so yeah
it's the problem ok ok this is natural
footage the animals and this animals
never seen itself in the mirror and
unlike all the claims in the literature
this rhesus monkeys grabbing spackling
mirror and staring at itself at
extremely close range while looking in
the mirror now this is fascinating for
the following reason first of all only
females did this hmm
secondly and more importantly why in all
the previous reports where a rhesus
monkeys have been tested do they
continue to act aggressively in this
case they don't here's one possible
explanation all the other tests are done
with full standing mirrors this is a
mirror you can grab around with you how
could you possibly be carrying around on
the rhesus monkey inside impossible the
physics rules out the alternative
explanation for them so we think what's
possibly going on here is that the
ability to carry around with you your
reflection rules out the competing
interpretation in the other situations
giving themselves the information that
seems to be needed to identify it as
themselves so we have here is not only
what seems to be absolute fascination
with their own reflection but pretty
much the first demonstration of a
naturally occurring evidence that the
animals are interested in themselves in
this particular way and although we
can't say this with absolute certainty
what seems to be a clear sex differences
in this population like at all monkey
populations males dominate females there
would be no problem for a male coming
over and grabbing the mirror from her
and taking it never I've seen this
happen ok it's not that not possible for
it to happen but we did not see it
okay so what I'd like to argue from this
first part of my talk is the following
that if we're interested in
understanding how certain kinds of
capacities have evolved which I
certainly am and I hope some of you are
then what we need to do is to develop
certain kinds of tools certain kinds of
experiments certain kinds of
observations that tell us what's going
on there have been of course infinite
numbers of pop psychological books
written on the mental lives of dogs the
mental lives of animals speculating on
what's going on and these speculations
are interesting because they give us the
groundwork upon which we can make more
progress but we have now a set of tools
in our hands such as these where we can
begin to explore in more detail what is
actually going on my conclusion from
this part of the talk is the following
that these experiments seem to tell us
that the animals do recognize themselves
in the mirror they leave wide open the
question of what is going on in their
head in terms of their own beliefs and
it's with that sort of claim that I want
to turn to the second part of the talk
which is what is going on in their heads
and how can we find out in my greets
painting here it's interesting of course
because we know what's going on in the
mirror and he's sort of flipping the
mirror image around and we can
understand that because we can form the
representation in our own minds in our
own minds I about what the reflections
should look like the capacity that we
have that I refer to the beginning of my
talk which was the capacity for
mind-reading is an incredible tool we
can sit here in embed intentionality and
and embed beliefs at an extraordinary
level look Charlie here can have a
thought z and a little Suzy can have a
thought about Charlie having a thought Z
and a little Bill can have a thought
about Suzy having a thought about
Charlie having a thought Z and we can go
on forever like that almost and this
capacity allows us to navigate in a
social world in a way which is
extraordinary and what's so interesting
about this is it seems that certain
parts of our brains are really
responsible for this and we know us from
a number of different avenues but one in
particular which is so telling is
something like autism whereas a complete
breakdown in many cases of this
capacity oh this capacity to realize
that others have Minds and the lists
have beliefs that are often very
distinctive from our own
what about nan Yuen animals and how can
we find out we don't have language we
can't ask them with language so how can
we tell let me tell you about a very
simple but elegant experiment that's
been run on a large number of normal
children and also on autistics and then
tell you about our version of this
experiment that we run in our lab at
Harvard with a cotton-top tamarins it's
a test which tries to ask whether an
animal or whether a human animal can
understand the notion of a false belief
this is critical because when things
happen that we don't witness we have a
belief that may be very very different
because of the transaction happened in
our absence here is the experiment a
child watches a puppet show between two
puppets Sally and Sally and blue and
with the polka dots and they're playing
the ball and Sally puts the ball onto
the blue box and says I'm going to go
outside and get something when I come
back in let's keep playing
so she splits while she's gone and takes
the ball out of the blue box and places
it in the green box and now Sally comes
back in and you ask the child where will
Sally look for the ball now if you
understand what's going on and you
understand that Sally can't possibly
know that it's been switched your
prediction should be size going to look
in the blue box but if you think your
worldview is shared by everyone your
prediction will be that she's going to
look in the green box that's wrong that
means you don't understand the notion of
false police three-year-old children say
that Sally will look in the green box
four-year-olds say the blue box
autistics say the green box there's
something going on here developmentally
and neurologically but here is a
fascinating twist in the story which
gives us our in to this experimental
procedure you ask the three-year-old
where is Sally going to look for the
ball the three-year-old looks at the
blue box and says the green box the
three-year-old seems to be predicting
accurately with its eyes but something
goes wrong when language comes in the
authors of this work Clements and pruner
suggest that the reason why something
goes wrong is because without language
they're making implicit or covert
representation of what's going on but
language forces them to entertain
the two hypotheses for whereas all you
might go explicitly they must make a
concrete representation in their mind
about what the alternatives are and
somehow language is screwing things up
now hold that sort of possibility in
your mind for a moment but now I just
think about this the eyes are telling us
something about what's going on in the
child's head and if that's true then the
eyes of an animal should be equally
telling okay so we use the eyes of our
tamarins to tell us something about
false belief we borrow a technique which
was developed within developmental
psychology and the technique uses a
little bit of magic and the idea is this
why is magic so interesting to us magic
is interesting and special effects are
interesting because we're constantly
being faced with violations of the way
the world works physical principles are
being violated by a sawed in half bodies
levitating people's faces being
stretched all over the place whatever it
is it's a violation it's interesting now
infants don't need necessarily come into
the world with an understanding of that
but if they do then they should be a
surprise and should look as long at
those violations when the contrasted
with things that are consistent with the
world that's the logic behind the
experiment I want to tell you right now
here is our version of the Salian
experiment an actor would come into a
room while a tamarin was seated in a
little transparent box and an
experimenter stood on one side of the
table the IFRIC came in shooting some
apple placed the Apple on a table and
gave the tamarind some shared some apple
and then place the apple in one of the
opaque boxes let's say box number two
and then the actor in the first
condition would tell you about leaves
the room now in this first condition the
boxes are transparent you can see where
the Apple is and now the actor comes
back in but before he does the
experiment removes the Apple from the
box number two into box number one now
the actor should be thinking coming in
the Apple was in box two it's where I
left it but now he should search in box
one and the less because he can see it
so the violation the situation is
searching in box two if the tamarins
think the actor wants the Apple but now
we run the controls for this procedure
in the next two situations in the next
one now the boxes are opaque and now in
the actor leaves the room the
move now looking in box one is a
violation
whereas looking in box two is consistent
and then the final control for this is
that now the actor stays in the room of
the opaque boxes and he witnesses the
apples moving from box to the box one
now you reverse again the expectation
now looking in box 2 is bazzara looking
at box 1 it's appropriate as he saw it
move there so in each case the actors
action is exactly the same the only
thing that differs is what the actor
should or should not know and all I'm
going to show you now the next slide is
last data slide which is what the
tamarins do in terms of how long they
look and here's what we find this is the
amount of time they spent looking these
are the three conditions transparent box
actor leaves opaque box actor leaves
opaque box actor stays no difference at
all the transparent box condition now
for some of you may think this is a
failure it's possible that it's a
failure but another way of thinking
about this as follows the tamarins love
apples apples are fascinating and they
are particularly fascinating in this
situation because the actor gives them
some so certainly reaching for the box
for the Apple now is and they can see it
is interesting because it's likely that
they're gonna have some Apple but for
some reason they find it equally
interesting when the actor searches in
the box there's nothing and more
importantly in some cases some animals
they would look at the actor opening
this transparent box and then look back
at the Apple desiring Li perhaps and
then come back to the transparent box so
this is equally interesting but we
couldn't pull apart at the difference
where we can pull apart the differences
in these two conditions and this is
critical because suggest the possibility
that what the tamarins are doing is
representing what the actor must believe
here looking in the Box where the Apple
now is is unexpected because the actor
can't know it's there here looking in
the Box where the Apple now is isn't is
bizarre because they saw it moved so
they're looking time of these animals
seems to be telling us something at some
level about what they know and it
suggests the possibility a first
possibility that tamarins have some
notion of a false belief what's unclear
is whether it's the same kind of
understanding that a three-year-old has
which is implicit covert they're not
quite aware of what it is
or whether it really is a form of
explicit knowledge we just can't tell
but this is the beginning and this is an
area of research was extremely in its
infancy we know very very little about
what animals believe what they know so
what I want to do is I'm going to leave
you at this part point of the talk with
a suggestion a hint that non-human
primates may have some understanding of
beliefs they may have in the words of
David Premack a theory of mind they may
have some capacity to mind-read let me
out turn to the third part of the talk
death is something that is on most
people's minds at some point in time in
their life it takes on all sorts of
different configurations in properties
in terms of what people believe about
death whether you believe in the
afterlife whether you believe that the
certain things should be done following
on the death of somebody in Uganda for
example a place that I work with someone
and dies there's a three-day ceremony
the first day is a day of mourning
people come from all over relatives
friends to the ceremony it's a full day
of mourning and then after that it's two
full days of parties and the reason why
in part there's this change from morning
to partying is because many people that
have come to the funeral they haven't
seen for a long time in fact they may
not see them for a very very long time
after everybody leaves so they both want
to think about the person who has just
died but they also want to enjoy the
people who've come
so beliefs changed all over the place
depending upon people's cultural values
depending upon one's beliefs and so
forth and this is very flexible but what
people can agree upon at some level is
that when somebody dies there are
certain things that happened that are
very different from when someone's alive
to animals have any understanding this
would they be able to make a distinction
between somebody in a trance like this
who in some senses lacked the key
while signs and somebody who truly is
dead if I'm walking down the street and
I see one of you and I say hi you were
good friends and so if I say hi and then
five minutes later I find you flat out
on the floor check your breathing don't
detect anything you're not really
breathing at all I can't smell any of
your nose call the Emmys to say sorry
you know she's dead Charlie sorry the
farm is later I see the street again let
me go wait a minute I said I fight
before you you were just like dead and
say well no not actually not and so I'm
fine and then a few minutes later I find
you again laid out now my second in the
counter I'm not gonna trust what I
thought the first time and I think you
know this person is just something's
happening here and my beliefs are gonna
change and they're gonna change in
important ways and they're gonna change
in important ways because our conceptual
apparatus is built in such a way that we
can take on new experience and modify
what we believe let me give you a
complete opposite situation
edie wilson harvard who many of you I
think have come to know through his work
on sociobiology but is also one of the
world's experts in the study of ants and
Ed Wilson described something very
important a long time ago in the 70s
that when ants die they are dragged out
of their colony and when he wants Noah's
well what is the mechanism by which they
recognize dead ants from living ants
well it turns out that when an ant dies
it emits a chemical called oleic acid
and if you take oleic a sand you put it
on a live in they are dragged out of the
colony kicking and screaming for an end
there for dead equals oleic acids very
simple to lock and key system it can't
be modified they don't seem to learn at
all from this kind of experience or from
the person hit him say excuse me I'm
still alive that's a different kind of
concept of death than sewing what we
have even though we can have hopes of
people coming back even though we can
think that there may be all sorts of
things that will change let me tell you
now about a couple more cases of animals
respiring a death which will now build a
picture which is perhaps a little more
complicated than we see in ants now here
is this a recognition of death monkey
hear no evil see no evil speak no evil
clearly recognizing something's going on
it's different to mean it's wrong
animals certainly age on the on of Cayo
Santiago we have many many old animals
that change that become lethargic
arthritic lose a lot of their
sensibilities presume they're coming to
the end of their lives is there a change
in the way they think about their
current lives do they reflect upon their
past do they wonder what it would be
like not to be around anymore in
elephants there are stories some of them
true about what elephants do when
another individual has died this is a
slide taken from an animal and a young
individual but I took it when I was
living in Kenya who was not gonna make
it in fact the infant died at the end of
this day this is a slide of its mother
trying to basically pick it up and move
it so it will walk it was this or get up
stumble down and fall over and the
mother with its trunk and as you can see
here it's like would sort of kick it and
try to get it to go and it wouldn't work
and eventually the infant died and
what's been reported in the literature
over and over again is that elephants
will come back to the dead individual
over and over again in fact will come
back to their dead bones their bones
pick up the bones and their trunks
manipulate them come back sit very
solemnly very quietly and looking at the
pile of bones what is going on in their
heads we can invent all sorts of stories
but really not clear what is going on in
their heads and if you're interested in
what's going on in their heads then we
need to take these observations much
further let me tell you one example of
this these are the the vervet monkeys
that I was studying in Kenya the verb
it's this doesn't seem to focus at all
so sorry about that
any case the vert monkeys are a small
old rule monkey closely related to the
rhesus monkeys and in this population
the following experiment was done to see
whether mothers could recognize the
voices of their infants they played back
of oka lies a ssin that infants give
when they're distressed and separated
from their mothers and they played back
this call through a speaker to a mother
and two adult females and when the call
was played back the mother looked to the
speaker and the two females looked to
the mother suggesting the possibility
that the females understand the
relationship that that is that mother's
kid what is she gonna do about it okay
the point I'm making here that I want to
anchor is that the infant's call has a
kind of a signature well during the two
years that I was in Amboseli
working on these vervet monkeys seven
infants died whose vocalization that
particular vocalization I'd recorded
before their death and I played it back
to mothers 24 hours to 48 hours after
the infants death
now for some of you probably think how
what a bastard we're a terrible trying
to do but think about it think of the
assumptions you've just made in
criticizing these type reacted it
already we don't know what they think
here is the result vii females play back
their call nobody responds Zippo nothing
nothing was going on at the time I
played the call back the females were
all resting sitting peacefully quietly
eating in a tree calling off not even a
detectable flinch now what's the
mechanism here is it out of sight out of
mind possibly this is 24 hours later in
the life of a verben infant intimates
are never away from their mothers for
more than about two hours so 24 hours
it's gone and predation is population is
massive 70% of the kids never make it to
their first birthdays so it's very
likely that a mechanism would have
evolved in this species for out of sight
is out of mind so maybe we're a little
bit closer at least we've got one
possible mechanism going on that would
make them respond to death in certain
kinds of ways but maybe it's no
different than what the ant does what
would happen if we brought the infant
back and then played the trick again
like in our discussion of walking
through town and seeing somebody who was
passed out twice in a row would they
change their
mines we don't know but now let me show
you another videotape from a species
where there's a little bit more
compelling possibly evidence it's in
part because it's a documentary there's
music behind it but I wanted just to
watch the response of this female
chimpanzee
since our babies too feeble to filter
she resorts to carrying it with her 40
she climbs in search of the food she
needs to survive
[Music]
then the gesture so human it's painful
to watch
she seems to beat her baby family
[Music]
[Applause]
I should hang out handkerchiefs or
something probably but so the the point
I'd like to make here and this in this
juncture of the talk is that we have
these fascinating observations these
observations that are so compelling to
us but they're compelling to us to a
large extent because we are unavoidably
empathetic creatures we can't turn it
off we see something even looks close to
what it means to be human and we
immediately jump to the conclusion that
it must be feeling or experiencing the
kinds of things that we do and it may be
true that what the chimpanzee is feeling
at the moment when it experiences its
own dead child that experience is very
much like what we experienced and
certainly given the close evolutionary
proximity between you and the
chimpanzees it seems like a reasonable
interpretation but the problem is that
behavior can often be a very misleading
guide to what's going on in the heart
and what's going on in the head so what
I would like to do now is turn to the
last part of the talk and talk them for
a moment about emotions and talk about
emotions as being the central core to
our thinking about morality in its
evolution let's take something that is a
very late developing emotion the child
embarrassment embarrassment is a
critical emotion if you are going to be
a moral creature because it suggests the
possibility that if you feel embarrassed
you have some feeling of guilt that
you've done something wrong or that
you're embarrassed by your action wasn't
quite appropriate wasn't quite right we
see cross culturally that the expression
of embarrassment comes in very similar
forms there's a covering up of the faces
a hiding deflecting the eyes and so
forth do animals show embarrassment and
how would we know is this rat
embarrassed
now we don't think that the rat is
embarrassed but how will we find out
behavior could be very very misleading
let's take something it looks a little
bit more like what we do when
chimpanzees are attacked and when other
non opponents are attacked they often
scream they scream very loud they
retract their faces they retract their
lips and they show we call a fear
grimace it's a very characteristic sign
it's very dramatic and exaggerated but
what happens in some primate species and
in not very many non primate species is
that following a fight
animals reconcile they make up for
what's going on they make up and very
interesting and very human-like ways
this is that same individual here who
now comes over to the dominant who just
pummeled it it offers its hand to its
mouth as a gesture and this is a sign of
trust I could bite you but I'm not going
to the fights over let's get back to
business males will come over who have
just been beaten in low rank email will
come over to the high ranking the animal
and offer their testicles to the male
who will hold on to them gently
this is trust as the word comes from
tests the mint this is trust and it's
done to keep levels of aggression down
it is a mechanism that keeps peace
within a society and we see it in spades
within the chimpanzees we see it in
lesser degrees within other non-human
species so these are the kinds of things
to do the kinds of emotion and kinds of
ways of dealing with emotion that would
seem to be at the root of our moral
status without these kinds of emotions
it seems impossible to evolve a moral
society now what I want to show you is
the last clip and then sort of last bit
of discussion is a fantastic case
recently that many of you I'm sure have
heard about but you probably haven't
seen the footage from and it's a
fascinating case of a boy who fell into
a gorilla enclosure at the Chicago Zoo
and it's the response that the female
gorilla shown here binti did when it
discovered this young boy
it's taken by a person who is subdued
[Music]
[Applause]
and the debate part was gonna be me
responding so I'll just do it in live
France of all who you her describe the
phenomenon falls in line with many
others who have described the phone line
talking about as the gorilla rescuing
this is a possible interpretation it is
possible certain that binti this
particular gorilla had some feelings
some altruistic feelings towards this
child to protect the child against the
other gorillas but there are
alternatives and if you're interested in
what was going on in been teased head
and in her heart then these alternatives
must be seriously entertained
we know that animals living in zoos have
a long history of interacting with their
caretakers it's possible to caretaker
trained binti to bring over any object
that was novel that was brought that was
falling into a cage her cage so would
binti respond in the same way to any
object that fell into her cage the
zookeeper apparently heard about my
snippy remark and said well look I once
dropped a bag of potato chips and she'd
bring that over but that's not the point
would she respond the same way if you
could possibly do the experiment you
probably couldn't to a live child how
would you respond would she respond the
same way to a teddy bear in order to
understand what banty was feeling in
which she was thinking these the kinds
of things you'd like to at least
entertain as possibilities now let me
tell you in sore conclusion now to cup
two experiments that I think gets a
little bit closer to a sense of morality
in particular a sense of empathy
because it's really being questioned in
the case of been teased did she feel
empathetic towards this child and is
that why she did it quickly here's the
experiment two rhesus monkeys are
trained to press the button or bar here
when the a light goes off to avoid being
shocked and they press the other lever
under the B light to get food and they
learn this very very quickly and these
are two cage mates now here comes the
interesting experiment shred over here
is put into an enclosure visually
isolated from Sam and Fred sees two
lights but he has no levers it's a video
camera filming Fred's face Sam over here
has no lights but he's got the levers
but he has a video monitor showing
Fred's face he learns it like that he
presses the correct bars and both avoid
getting the shot and both get food if
you put in an unfamiliar individual over
here doesn't work at all now it might
not work for two reasons it might not
work because Sam has no way of reading
the face of an unfamiliar individual II
just know what's going on you can't
quite argue that spite because of course
he gets shocked too but now let me tell
you about one more experiment which is
even more interesting a rhesus monkey is
put into an enclosure and the other side
of the enclosure separated by a
plexiglass partition is another rhesus
monkey when the one on let's say the
right hand side goes to reach for food
on his side of the enclosure the other
guy gets painfully shocked this rhesus
monkey will avoid eating food for three
to four days now this is fascinating he
is incurring a major cost of food
deprivation because reaching from food
gives pain to the other this opens up
all sorts of questions would they
respond the same way to an unfamiliar
individual what about other species
would they care in the same kind of way
would they generalize the way they feel
about a cage mate to others these the
kinds of experiments that I think tell
us a lot more about what's going on in
the hearts and heads of these animals
than the kinds of observations that are
useful as groundwork but then must be
further followed up with other kinds of
so let me conclude then with the
following statements we have an
extraordinary curiosity about
intelligent life forms outside of the
planet Earth and we spend millions of
dollars in searching for it and yet we
share a planet with a species there's
extremely closely related to ours
and we spend very little money on it
this is peculiar this is an intelligent
life-form it's a very intelligent
life-form and in many ways it shares
many things in common with us I think
we're at the beginning now of an
appreciation and what the minds of other
species are really like what they feel
and what they believe I don't have time
to show you today but there are some
interesting cases now of what people
might want to call a rain dance in the
chimpanzee that when the rain comes out
Jane Goodall described a case of
chimpanzees sort of going into euphoria
and dancing around is this the beginning
of ritualized dance we also have cases
of animals coursing together the
beautiful melodies of songbirds these
rituals these melodies these conventions
are these possibly the roots of our own
culture these are the kinds of questions
that I believe that with future studies
of animals what they feel in what they
think will give us new insights into our
own cultural systems evolved thanks
[Applause]
thank you more are there any questions
or yeah I guess so
you want to take well I think I was
careful to say hey I wasn't even
correctly wrong I said some autistics
and it's absolutely clear that some
autistics are absolutely incapable of
passing these tests so I hope I didn't
say but if I did I'll correct myself now
and say that the claim was for some
autistics where there are now some
possibly some diagnostic test for what
might be going wrong neurologically of
actual deficits that seem in very many
ways to parallel the kind of deficits
you can see with lesion studies in
rhesus monkeys let me just give you one
quick example just so I can clarify what
I said in rhesus monkeys is a part of
the brain it seems to be very much
involved in the detection of I gates and
understand what eyes mean and one of the
problems some autistics have is
understanding what the eyes tell us that
seeing is knowing for many autistics is
opaque if you lead in that area I have a
rhesus monkey they don't discriminate on
the basis of eye gaze okay some studies
are revealing now that those seem to be
areas that in some autistic to fail
those tests is damaged okay so yes by
all means there are very
high-functioning autistic
temple grounding the vet is a perfect
example of that but if you saw the New
York Times article she herself mentioned
romance novels what a mind-boggling
concept right so even in very
high-functioning autistic there is this
kind of problem so all I wanted to say
was that for some autistics okay and
clarify that problem of theory mine is
clearly not something to have a grasp of
yes yeah I it was kind of a throwaway
line but the one thing I would say is
the following that many things that have
become ritualized in animal behavior
grew out of just exactly that of certain
kinds of emotion for example the dance
of the honeybee which you may be
familiar with grew out of an intention
movement to fly which then became
ritualized and when we see over and over
and over again in non-human animal
societies is that expressions of emotion
often become ritualized and
conventionalized so I was throwing out
the rain dances possibly a case of
euphoria and jumping around that could
be conventionalized the question was
whether some of the issues that have
been discussed like empathy and
ritualization are based on genetic
predispositions or whether they are
learned behaviors that's a an immense
question a very profound question in
many ways and I would like to answer it
I guess in sort of two small bits one is
that my own view which is I think shared
by some people at least within the
cognitive sciences is that we don't want
to set up this dichotomy that we kind of
have lived over and over again since the
60s and earlier than that and we want to
entertain the possibility that there are
genetic predispositions to learn
that there is an instinct to learn and
that what our genetic biases give us our
attentional fossa on to certain kinds of
experiences that we attend to certain
things and that's as true of us as it's
true of any animal
so what experience can do to move the
system around possible degrees of
freedom that's open for all these kinds
of problems so what I would like to say
is that is empathy genetic I have no
idea I mean with what extent it is
whether genetic predisposition for
certain kinds of emotions yes we know
that and in fact if you look even within
certain primate groups like the macaque
switch there are many species there are
clear temperamental differences which
are genetic and you can move those
around a little bit
but only within a certain range rhesus
monkeys are really aggressive macaques
barbaric acts are really kind of nice
and some tell macaques are even nicer so
I think the only point would be to say
we don't really know yet how much the
genetic contribution is guiding these
kinds of experiences how flexible it is
yeah
if children pass so to speak the gallop
mark test at the age of about 18 to 24
months okay before this so it's quite
delayed because if you think about it in
18 to 24 month all the two-year-old
let's say has already got some language
they're producing words they're
comprehending words they've being a
string words together it syntactically
that child however does not have at
least a mirror self recognition they do
show a fascination with mirrors the
chimps I think I should have said this
the fascination the mirror is a somewhat
short-lived one that it's the initial
hit with a mirror that initially sets
off this kind of looking into the mouth
and so forth and then it dies down
pretty quickly so children also will
show a kind of peak in interest early on
and then of course it changes as they
get older the the other comparison which
is quite interesting this is me just a
short report on an experiment is the
chimpanzees also have an extraordinary
capacity to navigate spatially by using
a video monitor of their arm moving when
they can't see where it's going a
capacity we find very difficult when you
walk into a department store you see a
video image yourself use not only clear
where you're going chimps almost
automatically will figure out the
spatial coordinates through a video
monitors there's a sense of awareness of
spatial movement about the body that's
very very refined in chimpanzee so and
that kind of extraction has not been
done with children so there's a lot of
areas where the comparisons haven't been
as well sort you know done yeah
[Music]
it's a fascinating question in fact I
just I've just been seeing much I've
just been writing about this and we
don't know for example whether upon
contact with a mirror and now being
given this information whether it
changes their personality um have no
idea how this might alter the
personality of an individual now the
people have done this work don't think
that the mirror is giving them a sense
of self they think it's already there
they think of a sense of self as being a
modal not being restricted to the visual
modality but the thing that's
interesting about this also is if the
mirror test is somewhat misleading in
the following way some patients who have
damaged the visual areas experience this
deficit called prosopagnosia which some
of you may know about which is that they
fail to recognize familiar faces but
they can recognize all other visual
objects seems to be restricted to the
face and in some of these cases it
includes their own face now these people
have no problem telling you who they are
okay
it's not a loss of self at all so in one
sense you can see the mirror test is a
very misleading test in terms of notion
of salt because on that basis the pros
bec Nozick's fail so that's why I try to
make the distinction which I think
you're getting in terms of the awareness
and consciousness between self
recognition on the one hand and self
awareness and I think those tests up
simply mute on that problem and nobody
has yet come up with a better experiment
I mean the false belief experiment
begins to get at something like that
because you're comparing what you know
with what somebody else should know but
it's also possible if you're in street
talk about it later to pass a false
belief test like I showed without really
any recourse to the mind at all you
could just be a good predictor of
behavior so so there's even problems
there so nobody's really come up with an
elegant test yet determine what is going
on the animals have terms of any kind of
awareness of that ya know the mirror the
mirrors were all over them I mean
they're the broken fragments were
everywhere the second thing I would say
I'll just repeat is that the males are
dominant and if they wanted the mirror
they could grab it away but the Third
Point which then is very interesting is
that if you look at the literature on
tool use in animals it's always the
females there are the inventors and they
are typically the users in a population
of chimpanzees in Sierra Leone
the chimps feed on this fruit from a
tree called a cap Hawk tree which is
this huge thorn it's very difficult to
get the fruits the females have invented
what the authors call sandals and seats
they strip off bark and they put them on
their feet and they climb up the tree
like crampons and when they get to a
good patch they put some more into their
butts and they sit down and eat
peacefully only females now so
repeatedly the inventors seemed to be
the chimps and often I mean the females
and often the users are the females as
well and it then spreads slowly the
classic case right the potato washing
Japanese macaques
the adult males were the last ones to
get it the females got it first
especially juveniles and then lastly the
adult males so I have no idea now I
would say that in the rhesus monkeys
like all monkeys
females are they're really social
members of the society and males are
much less social it's the reverse in
chimpanzees but a monkey sized females
are close-knit social groups and males
are very distant elated and don't
interact very much weather hasn't gonna
do with it I don't know yes wasn't my
experience at all experiment
on familiar individual of the same
species the whole thing washes yeah I
mean and you know this was an old
experiment actually both experience I
describe one was done in the fifties and
one was on the 60s these experience
applied could not probably done anymore
because the ethics involved in you know
shocking primates that said the results
they got were that unfamiliar animal the
whole thing washes they didn't do the
other experiment where you had reaching
for food and shocking they only did you
know somebody that they knew no no this
is the sorry I described to experience
one was the leavers and that one was
done with the familiar cage mates fred
and sam nunn from there the other one
with the glass partition and the food
reaching for food and being shocked that
one was just one animal yeah yeah from
what you've described it doesn't seem
like we could test animal intelligence
anywhere near that was an article
reporting that dogs and cats have an IQ
of fourteen how can we test for IQ nails
I don't know what the claim for IQ is a
fourteen but but but let's take that to
me that the more serious question you
ask which is can we test for
intelligence and animals which is a very
important question I think it ends up
being the same kind of questions as
people will often argue for the IQ test
he's like who you test the test of
intelligence in humans and I think the
point I was trying to make in the
beginning and maybe I didn't make it as
elegans I could have is that the
question of intelligence is really in
touch question about specialization
given the environmental pressures that
an animal confronts and so to say let's
give a test of intelligence that we
think are intelligent behaviors well
let's ask us to echolocate and find
objects are we gonna do well well
actually no we're not okay so the point
is the tests have to be sensitive to
what the animals are doing and when we
make claims like for example look we
really think the chimps and the dolphins
and the gorillas and the orangutans and
the parrots are all smart beef they have
big brains that's a mistake I think in
thinking because
first of all it's not necessarily the
size the brain is telling us very much
about intelligence and secondly it has
to do with specializations of the parts
of the brain in the bat almost the
entire brain is dedicated to the
auditory cortex why because the bats
world is the auditory world that's all
it cares about so gassing into you know
tasks can you please separate these
objects based on your vision it's not a
good test okay so the point is that what
does seem to be happening with dogs and
cats and this is an interesting issue is
that certain kinds of tests that we know
are not problems for dogs and cats cats
based on their motor skills there's a
difference between what dogs do and cats
do and some of the interesting
intuitions there come from thinking
about the ancestors to the domestic dogs
and cats cats are a social animals dogs
are social animals in terms of social
intelligence okay dogs are far smarter
but that makes sense think about their
history so I think that question has to
be bounded in terms of the social
behavior in ecology that the animals
confronted in its past the kinds of
regularities that confronts which would
have favored certain kinds of abilities
over others yeah
three year olds and the rhesus monkeys
you choose the box which goes against
what they visually know and language
somehow impedes wouldn't you think why
would it impede would it just be kind of
a like a random you know they picked one
bomb he was in town the other two didn't
what basis would you say the language
impedes it conflicts with what they
visually know doesn't make any sense to
me I missed anything I think yeah okay
so the question is in the false belief
test with Sally Ann what is the issue
going on between what the three-year-old
child seems to be telling us with their
eyes and what they seem to be reporting
with their language what I was reporting
on is a distinction but the author's
drew from their own results the
interpretation they give is that when
the child is merely scanning the scene
what they're doing is making a simple
prediction with their eyes and they see
me making the prediction correctly when
they're being asked where will the
puppet go they're being forced
entertained one possibility over another
and for some reason which we don't know
they're making the wrong decision they
want to argue and I'm not saying this is
this at the right argument or the right
conclusion is that that's something
about using your language to keep those
two ideas in mind and then report on
them explicitly they somehow throwing
them off they don't understand the
mechanism or why or anything they are
merely speculative at one possibility
and the idea is simply this we know
there are a number of cases where what
you know you're not aware of your
knowledge and there other cases where
you can repeat to me but you are aware
of it okay and let me give you a good
example so maybe we just talked about
the pros of agnostic patients who lack
the ability to recognize faces that is
the ability the lack of ability is to
say that's Fred that's Ronald Reagan
that's Marilyn Monroe or whatever it is
okay but if you record from their skin
or if you record from their heart they
show
familiarity at that level that's the
distinction between being aware of what
you know and not being aware of what you
know and the interpretation for children
is that they're not aware that they know
what the correct answer is that could be
or it could be they when they get older
they think you want a specific answer
and they're going what they think you
want okay that's my interpretation it's
I mean your question is right in the
sense that we don't really know what
makes the difference between the
three-year-old the four-year-old okay
well what makes the difference between
reporting with your eyes and reporting
with your mouth but the the observation
sticks is an observation of a difference
in the accuracy of the prediction and
it's very distinctive as well yeah
intelligence like you said they show
social intelligence or that they have
what is it about the monkeys that makes
you think okay I I don't actually I use
intelligence the entire talk but I was
responding to a question about
intelligence but I think that the notion
of intelligence I would sort of
translate that into what kinds of skills
the animal brings to a task that allows
to solve that task and that in the
domain of social behavior primates to do
the pressures of being in the social
group are more sophisticated in the
following kind of way I can
operationalize it if you want due to the
pressures of living in a social group
that's like a primate social group what
you see in primates but you do not see
really in other animals to the extent is
coalition's form where animal a will
join together with animal B to beat up
animals see okay now that capacity
requires you to do a number of very
important things are difficult you have
to keep track of what you know about
rank relationships what that animals
rank relationship is whether they will
help you understand circumstances if not
what will happen okay now it gets
outrageous in dolphins where dolphins
were formed as super coalition's two or
three males will join up with two or
three other males against another
coalition to gain up and get a female
now that's complicated the sense of what
you have to remember okay now I don't
care personally to say that's more
intelligent
then a honeybee who can go off at
distance of 300 meters and come back and
say at 300 meters to the North East is
precisely the food you want to go get
that's bees intelligence you want to use
the word so I rather actually not use
the word intelligent talk about
specialization so in that sense the bats
are specialized for echolocation doesn't
make them more or less intelligent okay
the question is are there any examples
of animals acting morally in the case
where there might not be an advantage to
doing so the distinction I'd like to
make and I'm sure the lot people will
disagree with completely is the
following that in order to be a moral
creature he requires the notion of
agency the require the requirement to
act intentionally okay I don't think
we've got any evidence yet that suggests
that animals act with intention they act
in sophisticated ways by recognizing
differences in behavior and so forth so
the sting ssin I'd like to make is that
we see lots of behaviors which are
sensitive to the behaviors of others and
in that sense I would have to say that
animals are moral patients they sort of
deserving of our moral treatment but
they don't act moral because they can't
make a distinction between what's right
and what's wrong once we have enable a
show they do I leave open the
possibility that's true that said there
are lots of behaviors which look moral
okay I mean Jacques Cousteau reported
many many times you know diver drowning
in dolphins picking out the diver
bringing up too so they could breathe
moral on the count that they're
intentionally doing it yes and the count
that's something else No
so I think the distinction I like to
make is that until we can understand the
extent to which animals can act
intentionally and be agents aware of
their actions in distinction right and
wrong
we can't make the claim they're acting
morally yeah
yeah that's that's a good question the
the distinction that I didn't make I
didn't make clearly enough is the
following many many animals will follow
the direction of eye gaze that's a
highly adaptive behavior because
vigilance is so critical to most animals
who are preyed upon
okay so vigilance and eye scanning lots
of animals no need for theory of mind
there now the experiment old you about
what the tamarins the part I didn't tell
you about because I don't tell you all
the details here's the part of the
experiment the Terrans fail I told you
that they look longer when the actor
looks in the box where the Apple is if
they've been out of the room okay they
seem to make the correct prediction that
that's bizarre because I should know
where it is now just make the following
small changes rather than my leaving the
room I stay in the room but I closed my
eyes they fail or I turn around 180
degrees they fail they seem to need
absence to understand what's going on in
terms of the expectation of the actor
okay
so that's a sense in which the tamarins
do not understand that seeing is knowing
they seem to understand or at least this
is suggestive that absence means can't
know so it's a much core coarse-grained
analysis than what we're capable of
doing and again I can tell you if you're
interested after there's similar
examples of this and chimpanzees well
they seem to also fail this expectation
in addition autistic some autistics
again how this kind of failure here's a
very simple experiment with some
autistics if you do the following
experiment they fail two people stand in
front of a big open box one person looks
in and the other prints look straight
ahead and you ask who is more likely to
know what's in the box they're random
okay so there's a failure to connect at
some level what the eyes are revealing
in terms of knowledge and that seems to
be true for many of the animals
I hate to do it but we have to interrupt
we are finished with your time
thanks a lot more that was great
[Applause]